I'm curious is there anyone in this
audience that has died and come back and
would be comfortable to talk about
it
nobody all right somebody raising their
hand oh you're raising your hand that
makes me nervous can you
talk okay you know I didn't know I don't
want to be rude and ignorant like what
if she's like no I can't cuz I almost I
did die you piece of [__] okay you don't
have to stand sit down and relax young
lady what's your name my name is Betty
Betty hi Betty what happened to you
Betty I had an AAR rure where were you I
was I was
actually running track but you were
running track and it just burst inside
you and you did you drop I did did you
pass out I think I
did listen let me tell you something
Betty if you think you passed out you
pass the [__] out
if the part of your story goes the next
thing I remember you passed
out I'm not a medical professional but I
am positive of
that okay so you wake up where in an
ambulance woke up in oh in
air Jesus Christ you you're running like
yeah we're going to take steak and next
thing you know you're like what the [__]
happened man we win they got a
helicopter for the [__] States hell
yeah and they airlifting us over to
[__] Arizona right now godamn I'm
excited you woke up in a
helicopter do you know what the worst
part of that story is you
died that's my guess that's my
guess that's my guess the worst part is
that you die it's
not okay
it's wait say it again that's my mother
found out I wasn't
a that's what I'm talking about Betty
that's what I'm talking about
Betty good for you Betty living life
before you die girl that's what's
up [__] you never know when you're going
to die you could be running track your
[__] explodes and you're in a
helicopter thank God you gave it to
somebody Jesus
Christ Betty how old were you when that
happened I was 20 okay how old were you
and you lost your
virginity let's talk about it you put it
out there no pun intended no pun
intended Betty 16's reasonable I'll take
it I'll kill my daughter but I'll take
it from you sorry for you Betty but I
kill my
daughter kill
her how long were you dead uh
Jesus Christ Betty what day was it do
you have it do you remember the date you
don't even remember the date I would
hope You' celebrate it but for real when
I woke up from anesthesia I woke up
because literally an angel came through
the eth floor window s hospital and I
made my mother kneel and say that hold
on you can't tell your mom you lost your
virginity and then asked the woman to
kneel
to an entity coming in the window even
I'd be like
what what we doing here Betty how much
you've been around Betty how many times
have you lost that
virginity so you're telling me an angel
came through the window really good
really good describe it describe it just
was like a super bright light that would
you would think would blind you but it
didn't energy yeah you want to looking
and like said I another new catri
nutrition but by that time she forgotten
it she just found out her daughter
[__] lost her virginity probably
traumatized some [__] gets pushed out
when you hear [__] like that
Betty so you lost your virginity and
then you die at 20 ready how long before
you lose your new
virginity cuz you came back so you're a
virgin again how long before you lose
that virginity
and do you tell your
mom how long Betty was it like right
away you're like I don't know what's
going to happen tomorrow somebody
getting this
[Applause]
[__] my grandmother would kill me right
now my grandmother would kill me school
6 months later what I like your style
Betty hooked up with a high school x 6
months later I like your style I'm glad
you're still here Betty hold on how old
are you now if you don't
mind 69 hold how old 69 of course you're
69 of course you're forever 69 Betty you
know what I'm
saying of course you're
[Applause]
69 course of [__] Course and there
you go that's why we play the game y'all
someone's died on every Stop Salt Lake
City I'm fired up to be back back it's
been a minute but I'll be there Friday
October 27th and Saturday the 28th get
your tickets now at Ryan sickler
[Music]
[Applause]
docomo Ryan was absolutely hysterical
he's just so authentic love the show
Ryan it was fantastic love the podcast
love the Honeydew podcast so good to see
you live but I know I got to sign up for
the patreon you sign up for a year you
get over mon thank you so
much thank
you